he was on his way to buy some bread but
ended up at the police station
sixteen-year-old muhammad satel a
palestinian israeli
still doesn't know why
the moment he was detained was caught on
video
[Music]
one of them yelled that he ordered me to
stop and i didn't
then they dragged me and started hitting
me each time they asked a question
they wouldn't let me answer they would
just hit me muhammad was freed a few
hours later
his is just one story of many young
palestinians living in israel being
detained
often randomly in what is called
operation
law and order but for the palestinians
it's more an operation of intimidation
just a few days ago
police paraded here in jaffa giving
traffic tickets
to palestinians mostly the port city on
the suburbs of tel aviv
has been on edge ever since protests in
support of palestinians in czech
and occupied east jerusalem took place
and in many ways palestinians here
shared the same plight with many
families also facing forced expulsion
om mahmoud was sitting at home when a
group of people walked in with
restructuring plans and cameras
her home was sold by the state to a
nearby religious school
while she still lives there they tell me
to get out they want to kick us
out so my two sons were detained because
they are defending our home
that's a crime her sons are now under
house arrest
during the 11-day gaza war tensions were
very high between the two communities
and there were riots in several mixed
cities across the country
that actually took many by surprise here
since
the government has rounded up more than
1 500 people
the vast majority being palestinians
some were released within a few hours or
days but very few
jewish israelis were detained for their
role in the rioting
yara al-aloof was among palestinian
protesters when police cracked down
she admits that as a jewish citizen
there is a slim
chance she will be apprehended i've
never seen something like that here
in the past weeks i've been constantly
in the streets i didn't see
any jewish person being detained
in the same standards i mean you see um
people on a bike without helmet
and if they're jewish they just go by
and if they're palestinians they're
detained
for abid abu shahada there is a
concerted effort aimed at palestinians
wherever they are
it's a system that is working against
it's not a political it's not netanyahu
it's netanyahu and it's guns and it's
barack and it's the court system it's a
synchronized system that is working
against
as israel continues its wave of arrests
in the name of public order
peace between the two communities in
places like jaffa
will remain precarious
al-jazeera jaffa